Thanks for coming back.
Now you might be
asking yourself,
why are we talking
about security again?
I mean, we've already talked
about TLS and its use in HTTPS.
HTTPS as covers many
angles of attack
for things like eavesdropping
on your traffic,
or just impersonating the
web server as a whole.
However, the most secure
front door in the world
will not be worth
anything if there's
a letter to the
first floor window.
The letter being your web app.
HTTP contains some very
subtle security risks.
On top of that, the history
and backwards compatibility
of the HTTP protocol
carries a lot of baggage
from a time where security
wasn't as big of a topic
as it is now.
In this lesson, we
are going to learn
how certain design choices
could have allowed an attacker
to steal sensitive data, and
how you as a web developer
can protect you web app
against such attacks.